he'd do anything for me do anything for
the kids
four months ago there was hope jason
kelk the man who had been hospitalized
by covid longer than anyone else in the
country
took his first few steps since being
admitted to hospital in march 2020
but it was ultimately to be a cruelly
false hope
his wife sue says that last month after
jason contracted two infections
and suffered a relapse which saw him
having to be put back onto a ventilator
he decided he'd had enough he couldn't
do the things he was doing
he got more and more depressed
more and more fed up with everything
nobody could tell him how what was going
to happen
you know whether he'd get back to where
he was and if he did how
long for and i think he just he just
couldn't take it anymore he just
didn't want to he just just gave up
really
i think he'd fought so hard for so long
and he just couldn't face doing it again
jason a 49 year old it professional at a
primary school in leeds
had underlying health conditions asthma
and type 2 diabetes
he knew his best prognosis would still
mean a tracheostomy
limited physical exertion and dialysis
but for months he fought on i really
didn't know he had it
had it in him he's always been a bit of
a wimp really as far as
you know if he got ill it was
dramatic you know he was dying
and you know when he really was and when
he really needed to he found
strength from somewhere and
unfortunately
it wasn't enough jason was admitted to
st james's intensive care unit
at about the same time that derek draper
the husband of tv presenter kate
garraway
was also hospitalized mr draper has
thankfully now been allowed home
to continue his recovery with long
covered it seems that we are seeing
an emerging population of about 10 to 20
percent of people who've had
carbon 19 who develop longer term
symptoms going
forward we have to define a set of
criteria where we can actually then
assign a diagnosis a label of long
clover to these
types of patients to the exclusion of
other things like hey fever or other
chronic fatigue syndrome
related causes and then we can then
develop a treatment program for them
after over 14 months of hoping and
caring for jason his death has been a
devastating blow for his widow and step
family
but sue says the memories of her
soulmate and of his bravery in his final
hours
will last forever fraser moored sky news